i'm going to show you how to fix urinary
frequency once and for all out of all
the conditions that are out there this
one is a pain in the butt because
it interrupts your sleep here you are
just trying to rest and you're getting
up two three four times a night when i
was in practice there was a guy that
came in and he was getting up i'm not
kidding ten times a night now i'm going
to show you how easy it is to get rid of
this condition all you have to do is
understand the mechanism now urination
at night is called bacteria and it
happens equally in men
and women and urinary frequency is not a
problem with the bladder that's the tip
of the iceberg that is a symptom there's
something else going on and when you
understand it you can get rid of it and
it's not going to be taking any pills
it's just a shift in what you eat it's a
dietary problem but the main unnecessary
problem with this condition
is that it leads to
fatigue the next day and blood sugar
problems you're going to be craving
carbs the next day because a lack of
sleep will alter your blood sugars and
it affects cortisol which affects your
mood so you're grouchy and irritable and
it can even affect your cognitive
function your ability to concentrate and
your memory now if you actually do
research on this topic you're going to
find that
they're going to talk about it could be
a uti it could be an enlarged prostate
it could be a kidney stone it's usually
because you're drinking too much water
and all of these could be a factor but
there's something else that's way more
common now if you're a man
you've probably been told that your
prostate is enlarged so that's what's
causing your problem getting up at night
but here's the thing when you actually
treat in a large prostate
this symptom rarely goes away so the
treatment of the prostate doesn't fix
the bacteria and another question that
comes up is
you know you're told that you have too
much testosterone a certain type of
testosterone and that's why your
prostate is enlarged but then why is it
that testosterone decreases with age and
prostate enlargement increases with age
so there's all these confusions that
come up but here's what we know for sure
diabetics
nearly always have problems with urinary
frequency
what's the difference between a diabetic
and someone who doesn't have diabetes
high levels of sugar and many times high
levels of insulin unless they are a
diabetic type one here's the next clue
in a study related to dogs and i'm going
to put these studies down below it was
found that when you administer insulin
to these dogs you have a significant
output of urine these dogs start dumping
lots of urine here's another clue
insulin inhibits
the adrenal hormones that are supposed
to hold urine so the adrenals have a lot
of different hormones and one of the
hormones is supposed to retain fluid
well insulin blocks that hormone so
guess what's going to happen you're
going to release a lot of urine and the
last clue is this high levels of insulin
are nearly always found in
overactive bladder syndrome
now what is one thing that doctors never
ever test
insulin they check your blood sugars but
they never do a fasting insulin test
high levels of insulin nearly always
come before pre-diabetes
high levels of insulin are also
associated with insulin resistance and
many people both men and women
who have urination frequency at night
also have
metabolic syndrome they might have high
blood pressure they might have an
enlarged gut they might have blood sugar
issues they might have discoloration in
the lower part of the leg like these
different spots they might have edema or
swelling in the lower extremities
they tend to get tired after they eat
lunch they have to take a nap and they
can't go for a long period of time
without needing to eat so the most
likely situation that's causing your
urinary frequency is high levels of
insulin so the next question is
what causes high insulin
before bed and the answer is
snacking
snacking at nighttime is the number one
reason
for high levels of insulin throughout
the night
snacking
increases
insulin
eating
increases insulin and so does high carbs
i mean a lot of people know that it's
the carbohydrate in sugar that increases
insulin but they don't connect the dot
between the eating so even if someone is
consuming a low carb snack you're still
raising insulin so this is what you need
to do it's very very simple it's not
complicated it's going to produce some
quick changes it might take a couple
days to work but it will work number one
stop snacking at night
take the snack that you would normally
eat at night and push it to your dinner
and don't eat anything after 6 30
pm
and don't drink anything past 6 30 pm
just make sure you drink enough food
fluid to the day but don't drink at
night because the combination of high
insulin and that extra water that you
drink before you go to bed will
definitely keep you up all night long
all right so if you just do that you're
going to see some really amazing changes
but the other two things you need to do
is start cutting your carbs down to
less than 30 grams per day that is
called the ketogenic diet that's going
to really help you so you can sleep
through the entire night and not get up
at all and when you're doing a low carb
diet you also want to add intermittent
fasting to that if you're new to my
channel and you would like more
information on that i created a very
short playlist with three very simple
and short videos i put it right here
check it out
you